think fast
i'll show you this later for right now
we're going to unpack how to be a quick
thinker
in conversation my name is chad
littlefield i love thinking about how
we create conversations that really
matter and you might be watching this
video
because you want to be a faster thinker
in conversation and not feel like you're
just
caught with these awkward pregnant
pauses
and in this video i'm going to share
some pretty mind-blowing science of how
fast our brains can actually move
in conversation and two strategies that
you can immediately use the minute this
video is over
to be a quicker thinker in conversation
and here's the promise
if you get to the end of this video and
you feel like what i've shared doesn't
actually
help you be a quicker thinker in
conversation you can write me an angry
email
and i will actually send you a deck of
cards that will make you a quicker
thinker
this offer applies to like the first 100
angry emails that i receive and nothing
beyond that let's get into it
[Music]
all right have you ever heard of the 125
over 400 rule
the human brain can listen
to up to about 400 words per minute but
the human mouth
can only speak on average at about 125
to 175
words per minute even like professional
auctioneers who are talking really
really really really fast
only speak at like 350 words a minute
meaning that even an action it's why we
can understand an auctioneer sometimes
it's why we can understand auctioneer
because our brains can listen
much faster than our mouths can speak
and
in this fact lie is a really important
idea which is
you can train yourself in conversation
to be a really quick thinker
and one of the easiest ways to be a
quick thinker to have quick responses
because that's the point because
you don't want to just be a quick
thinker
and just be thinking in conversation
right you want to be a quick thinker and
you want to respond with something
useful meaningful
in that moment and so in this video
we're going to unpack two strategies
that will
help you think much more quickly the
first
is hidden behind this lovely piece of
white paper and
it comes from improv improvisation jazz
in particular jazz musicians when they
would jam together
no written music but they'd come and
this
beautiful piece of music would flow out
of this improvised piece of jazz
it's really cool unscripted which is
how most conversations are right
unscripted and so how do they do that
how do they think so quickly how do they
adapt so quickly to each other
an improv teacher would say they did it
with these two lovely words yes
and and the idea and the mindset here in
improvisation
is that you're building right you're
always building on what somebody else is
saying so imagine if you were listening
at 400 words a minute
and you were saying in your mind your
your response you didn't have to think
about how to respond because you knew
your first two words were going to be
yes
and and you built on top of what they
were saying
as opposed to uh in you know in improv
as opposed to
no but or no because right which will
shut down a conversation
now let me be clear you might not
actually respond with
by saying these two words verbally you
might not literally say
um well stephen tell me something about
your family i
have a brother who's adopted yes and
that's really cool right or yes and
my business partner will is actually
also adopted right so
you might not actually respond with yes
and because painfully awkward now let's
try that again
stephen what is something tell me
something about your family my brother
is still adopted
whoa super cool um uh
you're saying that it's making me think
immediately of my business partner will
who was also adopted the first chapter
of our book is actually about this
really phenomenal story and connection
related
to that right so the ucl one feels a
little bit more natural so you might not
use these words but the idea is that i
was building on something that stephen
was saying
in that moment so you got strategy
number one yes and build on what they
were saying
i would say even cooler than that i'm
going to adapt the strategy i'm going to
add to the library of beautiful
insight that exists in the world on how
to do yes and
i'm actually going to say let's get rid
of yes and
and turn yes and into
yes ask question mark
yes ask because in conversation
when you think about how to be a quick
thinker in conversation
most likely if i were to guess and i
don't know your situation in your
context
but most likely you want to be a quick
thinker you're thinking about being a
quick thinker
because you want to know what to say
in response to what somebody else has
shared and that is actually a lot harder
i would say
than listening at 400 words a minute and
just thinking about
what are you going to ask afterward you
know kids between the ages of 3 and 5
ask between 300 and 400 questions per
day
adults ask between 6 to 12 questions per
so somewhere along the line our
curiosity went
way down and i would say this tool of
yes
ask makes you not only a quick thinker
but a really phenomenal
conversationalist i'm not saying that we
should go back to 300 to 400 questions a
day
but if we were to even double our count
you would appear to be a quicker thinker
in conversation but maybe more
importantly that person would feel seen
heard and
understood in the way that you were
responding that conversation and i would
argue that that is more important
than just being a quick thinker because
it's way more important
to be interested rather than interesting
and you got to remember with this yes
ask curiosity is a choice even if you
don't identify
as somebody who is naturally genuinely
curious it's a switch you can turn it on
at any given time and you can turn it
off at any given time
if you like this i've created two card
decks called we engage
cards and we connect cards and they're
really phenomenal there's two exercises
in particular there's an exercise called
story
swap with we engage cards and there's an
exercise called
conversation roulette really cool deck
of cards for
a in a work context or an education
context
to promote quicker thinking great way to
warm up a brainstorming session
really remarkable way to create
conversations that matter and get
some comfortable conversation flowing so
if you want to free digital versions of
either of these during the links below
if you want these things mailed to you
there's also links for that as well i'm
chad and i hope that you
have an awesome day